ان دستم على خطوطنا الحمراء فلا
تلومون الا انفسكم. هكذا توعد
بوتين الكيان الاسرائيلي
والمانيا في فوهة مدفع الدب
الروسي. وموسكو تحدد الدولة
التالية لحربها بعد اوكرانيا.
فما هي هذه الدولة? وقمة اوروبية
عاجلة في اوكرانيا وحاملات
الصواريخ الروسية تتحرك في
البحر. فما هو هدفها? والاتحاد
الاوروبي يدق يده على صدره ناثرا
وعوده يمنة ويسرة لاوكرانيا.
وبريطانيا تعلن تحدي الروس بسلاح
خطير في اوكرانيا. جاسوس الصيني
يتسكع في الاجواء الامريكية
والكندية. وترامب اسقطوه فورا.
وواشنطن ترد باربع قواعد عسكرية
جديدة في محيط الصين. بيم جونغ
يعلن غضبه على الولايات المتحدة
ويحضر النووي والسعودية تتقرب من
العراق فيما السودان يتجاهل
الجرح الفلسطيني ويوجه طعنة غدر
للعرب.
روسيا تتوسع خارج اوكرانيا.
انتهى التهديد وحان وقت العقاب
والاراضي الاوكرانية ما عادت
تتسع لحرب الدب الروسي التي
يتوسع نطاقها شيئا فشيئا. وبوتين
يتوعد اسرائيل على تجاوزها
الخطوط الحمراء برد عسكري
انتقامي وذلك في حال تسليم تل
ابيب اسلحة الى كييف بعدما قال
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه يدرس هذا الامر.
واضاف بوتين ان محاولة اسرائيل
الانضمام الى حلفاء اوكرانيا
ودعمها بالاسلحة الاسرائيلية
الحديثة هو تهديد لموسكو.
اسرائيل تخشى خسارة صلاحيتها في
الهجوم على ايران في حالة كسر
حيادها في اوكرانيا لصالح كييف.
تدوس تل ابيب على خطوط بوتين
الحمراء. بوتين لم ينتهي يا
سادة. وهنا يتعهد بالرد على ما
وصفه بالعدوان الغربي الجديد على
روسيا من خلال اوكرانيا قائلا ان
النازية في شكل حديث تهدد بلاده.
وان عليها ان تصد مجددا عدوان
الغرب الجماعي. واضاف انه بعد
ثمانين عاما تعود اليهم الدبابات
الالمانية مجددا. محذرا من ان من
يدفعون المانيا الى حرب روسيا لا
يدركون ان الحرب ستكون وان الروس
قادرون على الرد. ليعلن وزير
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف عن
الوجهة الجديدة للحرب. فهي ليست
الا مولدوفا حيث قال لافروف انها
قد تكون المشروع الجديد المعادي
لروسيا بعد اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان
الغرب يسعى لهزيمة استراتيجية
لروسيا لا تتعافى منها لعقود
لكنهم لن يسمحوا بذلك وفق قوله.
وهنا دولة اخرى تعلن تجاهل
تحذيرات بوتين وتغامر بمواجهته.
نعم انها بريطانيا حيث قال وزير
دفاعها ان بلاده لا تستبعد امداد
اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتلة لكنه
اعتبر انها لن تكون عصا سحرية
تغير مسار الحرب بسرعة وفق
تعبيره. واكد انه منفتح لبحث
جميع انواع المنظومات وليس
الطائرة فقط لمساعدة لكن اخبرني
من سيساعد بلادك يا هذا لتخرج من
ازمتها الاقتصادية والاضرابات
التي تجتاح المملكة قبل ذلك خرجت
المتحدثة الروسية ماريا زاخاروفا
ذات الردود اللاذعة لترد على
تصريحات ماكرون بان تسليم
الطائرات المقاتلة لاوكرانيا لن
يؤدي الى التصعيد. قائلة ربما
سيوزعون البسكويت والحلويات من
هذه الطائرات. اليس كذلك? انتم
اللي جبتوه لنفسكم. وهنا نعود
الى اجواء المعارك في اوكرانيا.
حيث قالت رئاسة الاركان
الاوكرانية ان قواتها تصدت
لمحاولات تقدم روسية في عشرة
محاور قتال في اقليم دومباس
بينما قال الرئيس الاوكراني
زينونسكي ان هزيمة روسيا باتت
واضحة لكنها من الناحية
التكتيكية تمتلك موارد للمحاولات
الهجومية. لتعلن المخابرات
الاوكرانية ان لاحظت تغييرات في
نشاط القوات البحرية الروسية في
البحر الاسود وقالت ان تلك
الانشطة تزيد وتنخفض بسرعة
وحاملات الصواريخ تتحرك ذهابا
وايابا. فما الذي يخطط له الروس
اذا? لتأتي الاجابة من اوكرانيا
حيث حذر مسؤول كبير في الامن
القومي الاوكراني من ان روسيا
تستعد لاقصى قدر من التصعيد
للحرب في اوكرانيا. ربما في غضون
القليلة المقبلة بحسب سي ان ان.
لتتحضر القوات الاوكرانية
بتدريبات عسكرية على استخدام
الدبابات في خركيف وسط مخاوف من
الهجوم الروسي المحتمل. فقد قال
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني وليكسي
رزميكوف ان تقديراتهم تشير الى
ان روسيا استدعت نحو خمسمائة الف
مقاتل من جنود الاحتياط. هناك
شهدت كييف قمة للاتحاد الاوروبي
التي تعتبر القمة الاولى من
نوعها منذ بدء العملية العسكرية
الخاصة وتأتي بعد منح اوكرانيا
صفة دولة مرشحة للانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي. فهل حان وقت
انضمام اوكرانيا للاتحاد لا يزال
ذلك بعيدا حسب الخبراء. ليعلن
مسؤول سياسة الخارجية في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزي بوريل ان المجلس
الاوروبي اعتمد حزمة مساعدات في
اطار مرفق السلام الاوروبي الذي
المزيد من المساعدة العسكرية
للقوات المسلحة الاوكرانية تشمل
حزمة جديدة خمسمائة مليون يورو
وخمسة واربعين مليون يورو اضافية
لدعم بعثة الاتحاد لتدريب القوات
الاوكرانية. بكين تخترق اجواء
واشنطن. من الارض يصلون. ومن
البحر يتنصتون وهي الصين تتجسس
على الولايات المتحدة حتى واجواء
امريكا مخترقة يا سادة. وبعد ان
رصدت واشنطن تجسس صيني يحلق في
سماء الولايات المتحدة اوضح
مسؤول امريكي ان المنطاد حلق فوق
شمال غرب الولايات المتحدة حيث
توجد قواعد جوية حساسة وصواريخ
نووية استراتيجية في منشآت تحت
الارض. على الفور استدعت وزارة
الخارجية الامريكية القائمة
بالاعمال الصيني في واشنطن بشأن
التجسس هذا وذلك وفق صحيفة لترد
الخارجية الصينية. ان الصين دولة
مسؤولة وتلتزم بالقوانين الدولية
وليست لديها النية لانتهاك اراضي
اي دولة او مجالها الجوي. واضافت
الوزارة الصينية في بيانها ان
المنطاد جسم مدني طائر يستخدم
للبحوث تأثر بالرياح الغربية
وبقدرة محدودة على القيادة
الذاتية انحرف بعيد عن مساره
المخطط له. وان الجانب الصيني
يأسف لدخول السفينة الجوية غير
المقصود الى المجال الجوي
الامريكي. ليدخل الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب على خط ازمة
منطاد التجسس الصيني داعيا
لاسقاطه فورا. لكن ما لن فالتجسس
لم ينتهي بعد. لتعلن وزارة
الدفاع الوطني الكندية انها رصدت
منطادا تجسس على ارتفاع عال
وانها تتعقب تحركات نشاط بدون ان
تأتي على ذكر الصين. فما الذي
يخطط له اصحاب العيون الضيقة?
ومن حرب المخابرات الى
الاستعدادات العسكرية. واشنطن
تعزز وجودها العسكري في محيط
الصين حيث اعلنت الولايات
المتحدة والفلبين عن اتفاق يسمح
للجنود الامريكيين باستخدام اربع
قواعد اضافية في الفلبين للتصدي
لتصاعد نفوذ الصين العسكري. الرد
الصيني لم باعلان بكين ان ولوج
الولايات المتحدة لمزيد من
القواعد العسكرية في الفلبين يضر
بالاستقرار الاقليمي وهي خطوة
ستزيد من حدة التوترات الاقليمية
بحسب الحكومة الصينية. يونج يونج
ترد بغضب. وفي حين غفلة وهدوء
كوري شمالي. اعلن الحلفاء عن
وجودهم هنا قالت كوريا الجنوبية
انها اجرت مناورات جوية مشتركة
الولايات المتحدة. استخدمت
خلالها قاذفات استراتيجية
ومطاردات خفية لتحلق الطائرات
فوق البحر الاصفر الواقع بين شبه
الجزيرة الكورية والصين في اول
تدريبات من هذا النوع تجرى هذا
العام. تلك التدريبات اثارت غضب
الجارة الشمالية لتحذر بيونج
يانج من انها سترد باستخدام
القوة النووية الساحقة في اي
مواجهة مستقبلية والمواجهة
الكاملة بمواجهة كاملة. مضيفة
انها غير مهتمة باي اتصال او
حوار مع الولايات المتحدة طالما
واصل هذا البلد سياساته العدائية
بحسب وكالة روتين. الاحداث
والتطورات. وزير الخارجية
السعودي فيصل بن فرحان في
العاصمة العراقية بغداد في زيارة
رسمية لاجراء مباحثات مع كبار
المسئولين العراقيين حول
العلاقات بين البلدين على الخليج
العربي. ووزير خارجية العراق
فؤاد حسين يقول ان التعاون مع
السعودية مستمر في كافة المجالات
طالبا من المملكة تزويد بلاده
بالطاقة الكهربائية من خلال
الشبكة السعودية او الخليجية.
وزير الخارجية الاسرائيلي يعلن
تطبيع العلاقات مع السودان. ماذا
عن القضية الفلسطينية ايها
السودانيون? ما الذي جرى لكم?
صوت مجلس النواب الامريكي
استبعاد النائبة عن الحزب
الديموقراطي الهان عمر من لجنة
الشؤون الخارجية بالمجلس على
خلفية انتقادات سابقة لاسرائيل
وذلك بعد ايام من استبعادها من
لجنة الشؤون الافريقية بالمجلس
وفقا لما اوردته شبكة سي ان ان.
الكيان الاسرائيلي والمانيا
ومولدوبا امام خطر مواجهة الدب
الروسي فايهم سيصبح الفريسة
الاولى امام الروس. محمد